if you're not quite finished waging war  and for honor I've got good news the  game's second season called shadow and  might kicks off soon I'm Tony and this  is your battle forged GameSpot news  update for Honor's season 1 has ended so  any faction Wars you participate an hour  just for fun but it's also the perfect  time to change your alignment and team  up with whatever Knights Vikings or  Samurai you passed on the first time  around and it's not just new rewards  coming with season 2 for honor is  getting two new heroes shinobi for the  samurai and Centurion for the Knights  and a new epic tier of gear new maps are  also on the way so for more details on  those don't forget to Like and subscribe  for honor season 2 kicks off on may 16th  on all platforms  that's ps4 Xbox one and PC then you'll  be able to rank up with the new warriors  and for a more fictional battle you can  check out our Dawn of War 3 documentary  [Music]